this is the khan academy exercise on
relative maxima and minima and they ask
us to mark all the relative maximum
points in the graph like always pause
this video and see if you can figure out
which are the relative maximum points
okay now let's work through this
together and just as a review a relative
maximum point is a point of the graph
where the values of the graph around it
are going to be less than or equal to
the value of the graph at that point
so for example this point right over
here would not be a relative maximum
point because if we go to the right of
it the function is larger than at this
point it has a higher value than at this
point
this point over here which looks like a
peak of a mountain and that's a pretty
good giveaway if it looks at the top of
a hill or peak of a mountain for a form
of relative maximum point this looks
like a really good candidate
if we move to the right a little bit we
get lower values for our function and if
we move to the left a little bit we get
lower values of our function and so this
is a relative maximum point let's do
another example
here they say mark all the relative
minimum points in the graph
well a relative minimum point is a point
of the graph where if we were to look at
the values of the graph around it
they're all going to be the same or
higher
one way to think about it this would be
the bottom of a dip in the graph and you
see one big dip in this graph and the
bottom of it is right over there so that
would be a relative minimum point and
you can see if you have the x values
around it the values of the function at
those x values are all going to be the
same or higher than the value of the
function right at this point that's not
true for any of the other points that we
can see of this graph